In Turkey, prosecutors say the twin bombings at a peace rally that killed 102 people...
...in Ankara earlier this month were ordered by the Islamic State militant group.
In Russia, the first Russian serviceman confirmed dead in Syria...
...is laid to rest in the small village of Grechanaya Balka, with hundreds in attendance.
In Iran, two Iranian Revolutionary Guard members killed in Aleppo, Syria were buried.
Tehran accepts invitations to Syria talks in Vienna, Austria.
In the United States, the Republican majority in the US House of Representatives...
...endorse Wisconsin Congressman Paul Ryan to serve as speaker.
And finally from Nepal, parliament elects Vidya Bhandari...
...as the first female president of Nepal on Wednesday.